sheen looking back at your life and all
the things that you went through that
that sound like they're pretty painful
and they would hurt most of the
population would you change your life or
would you say you know what maybe if I
had it too comfortable it wouldn't push
me to make these films go so many people
talk about doing this stuff and they
don't either do it or they don't finish
it so you're finishing it you're even
taking five years to believe in
something which is pretty commendable so
would you change all that yeah yeah you
know I really don't know i mean there's
because there's so many things that
could be changed so it's like at what
point do you it's all I you know it's
like those time travel movies you know
what at what point i forget the term
that at what point do you you know like
say there's 30 infant things traumatic
things that have happened do you start
from the first one I think my thing of
the butterfly effect or some reason like
you know what point do you make that
splice you know because I mean life a
lot of these things I've had a lot of
these things happen works like these big
events I guess you know and they started
when I was five so it's like at what
point would i if i change anything like
at what point would i do that i don't
know you know i mean most of my think
most of what i make i think is about
like lost childhood or rape or incest
you know and I mean that goes back to
when I was five years old you know
somebody thought I was being sexually
abused because a picture I drew and and
then that put me in foster care for two
years you know and then my one year old
brother ended up you know living with
his foster family till he's 18 so it was
my only sibling I never really had a
sibling and to this day I still kind of
feel responsible for that and it to this
day well he finally strike he's 30 now
he finally stopped questioning that when
he was like 27 28 you know so it's only
just recently where he's stopped kind of
getting in my mom's face about why did
you give me up you know and you know to
my foster family and and that all dates
back to something I did you know because
I do a picture that grown-ups
misinterpreted but um you know my life's
never been the same so it's like what I
you know they caused my family to you
know moves you know you know counties it
caused me to never have a sibling you
know and it gave my grandma stroke you
know the stress cuz she was like 75 at
the time and and even my daddy was only
35 at the time and he thought he was
having a heart attack turned out it was
just gas like he was so stressed he was
like creating all this you know gas that
made him feel like he was having a heart
attack and it just I'm in a date so many
lives were ruined from that so lots of
times I think what if I didn't just draw
that picture but I was five so
it's like you know I think like God my
imagination like you know I was even too
risque even back when I was a
five-year-old you know what's wrong with
me like I think about that sometimes too
like what's wrong with me why why would
I you know draw something what was what
was I thinking when I drew that you know
you know so I don't know at what point
would I take something back you know
because I think about that all the time
so obviously it haunts me
but then again who the hell knows where
I'd be if none of this stuff happened
and I wouldn't have all this anger
towards you know it's a not societal
society but the system to law
enforcement like I have so it's such a
rebellious attitude towards Authority
and you know and it all started with
that you know and I mean you know I
don't know there's so many things where
it's like I was sort of taking that back
but maybe then this wouldn't happen I
mean or I wish I would you know could
take that back or I wish I never would
have said I was gonna make that human
trafficking movie because then I
wouldn't have that whole reputation but
then that made me end up making the
Alyssa movie but then who knows how
that's going to be perceived so maybe I
shouldn't have made that you know I mean
there's so many things that have
happened where i'm like i don't know if
i would take down oh it's a really hard
question that I I don't know what drives
me necessarily because I've loved movies
you know since I was a little kid and I
wanted my dream was to make Van Damme
movies you know to star or direct you
know star under direct Van Damme movies
and that's nothing like the movies I
make I mean I'm so far from making those
kind of movies so maybe it would have
been better if that stuff can happen
because maybe I'd be making action
movies and fun movies not all these
depressing I want to kill myself kind of
movies you know maybe that doesn't help
me maybe just makes me kind of live in
that misery I don't I don't know you
know I mean that's really I don't really
know how to answer that would you push
yourself to make them I might I might
have I mean I loved movie I loved see
now it's not even like I love movies now
it's like it's like I have to do it
which could be better but it's like
there's no that's not necessarily
enjoyment anymore you know and I try to
like go wow it's like The Expendables
movies and get enjoyment like that back
and sometimes I do but I am it's more
like no I want to watch something that
depresses the out of me is that
healthy you know I don't know so so you
do sometimes wonder whether it relates
back to that picture at five years old
or other things if if maybe things were
more Ozzie and Harriet
and and perfect sort of picket white
fence where would you be now but maybe
you wouldn't have that same drive inside
you to make these films because it's not
easy to make filmed in a lot of people
talk you know we already went down there
and I brought that up but have you
thought about that that may be all that
happened but it also pushed you to put
these stories out that maybe if stuff
was too easy you wouldn't have done
anything yeah I mean I definitely think
that that's the case but um but what
I've been in a better place if not that
had happened I was making cool action
movies I guess is the thing you know I
mean cuz like you know life's short so
like maybe it would have been better if
I was just having fun making movies and
not so serious you know you know maybe
you'd be better if I was not pushing
myself because I had to but pushing
myself because I wanted to you know I
feel like I pushed myself because I have
to not because I want to or because I'm
having fun you know I mean I am having
fun here you know there but it's more
like you know he'd been looking back at
stuff i made like depresses me because i
think about the mindset i was in you
know I don't think about necessarily the
shot her you know
the filmmaking aspect I think more about
the the mind set the mood the emotion
which is what I love though too I mean
it's a really hard question because like
I want to feel emotional when I watch
something but like I said life's
short so maybe it'd be better to just
feel fun and bliss and you know like
often never never land when you're
making movies I don't it's a hard
question
you